this is my grandad's 1964 monolithina
eight millimeter action camera
[Music]
this is him and that's me
i have got the eight millimeter camera
in its underwater housing i need to
prove that this thing is just as cool as
a gopro
let's go find the field
ever since digital video cameras were
introduced into the market in 1993 with
the ampex dct the question of which
looks better film or digital has been
widely debated where the more purist
filmmaker would sway by phone and a more
new age high volume efficient sports
action filmmaker wouldn't even think
about touching it both film and digital
have their place yes
or do they digital is obviously far more
attainable it's cheaper it's lighter and
to get the footage off of it you can
just take out an sd card whereas with
film the process just feels so much more
organic but it's very expensive it's
finicky it's unreliable and it takes a
hell of a lot of time to process in this
video i'm going to focus on consumer
model video cameras the gopro hero 10
versus the 1964 monotina 8 millimeter
camera as a comprehensive experiment
that will answer the question does film
actually look better than digital and to
see if you can even tell the difference
between the two i call the eight
millimeter in action compatible camera
as it's the lightest smallest consumer
friendly and most durable out of its 16
and 35 millimeter counterparts
essentially it is the gopro of the 1960s
this video is not sponsored by gopro i'm
going to be highly critical on both
cameras however it was sponsored by my
good friends at epidemic sound which is
the greatest sound and music library on
the internet but more on that later
here's an animation made for you to
explain very simply how each of these
cameras work the gopro hero 10 can shoot
up to 5.7 k resolution and records 240
fps slo-mo it has amazing auto exposure
hyper smooth stabilization decent
battery life hours of record time and
compatibility with over 30 accessories
all for only 400 us dollars on the other
end we have our eight millimeter camera
which shoots on film that can be
digitized at 4k resolution shooting
frame rates of either 12 16 or 24 which
means no slo-mo it has its exposure
locked based on what film is loaded it
has no form of in-camera stabilization
and it lasts pretty long on a few
double-a batteries but only records for
2 minutes and 40 seconds per cartridge
the cost of shooting 5 minutes on this
camera totals to around 1
356 us dollars including shipping from
south africa plus the cost of the camera
which you can get in pretty good nick
second-hand condition for around 70
at first glance it's clear that the
gopro stands out as the go-to action
camera but does the stereo digital
footage it captures give you the same
emotional response as the grainy and
nostalgic eight millimeter phone
in order to make these two cameras
somewhat compatible this being
waterproof i'm gonna have to waterproof
the eight more camera in this waterproof
bag and create two one minute long
action sports films and then you can be
the judge which one's better okay
let's do this
so that there'll be no break in the
community service
let's begin
that's right
24 frames a second that's all i have and
on frost movements like this like half a
second
an action digital camera like gopro
gives you a lot more chance to
experiment but kind of get complacent
with the creativity i feel like with
film you have to plan there's this
process it's kind of romantic
this is my good friend chris rogers
chris is like a pro at the start
yeah look oh no wait that's pretty sick
okay let's go
i hate how much easier it is to shoot on
this i want to try and prove that film
still has a place it definitely has a
place a place in my heart
[Music]
camera broke again if i shoot with a go
easy bruh can you zoom on your gopro
let's go
[Music]
it'll work
i've got this light on the top because
the foam stuck in here is pretty dark
and i'm worried let's go find the steel
i think i got a feel i just hope it's
not too dark
i thought it was going to fight me just
finished the cartridge so i'm going to
swap out careful
make sure that i'm shooting 24 frames
i have no idea if i'm going to be able
to hear it railing out there
a little bit of water got in here i
think all messed it up
nice ride nice man you're ripping guys
can get so much closer with the gopro we
are in the joe studio with my half pipe
back with the legend janine on a
skateboard we have like five foot of
foam left so i'm just gonna roll that
out and then we're gonna wrap
[Music]
the thumbs up
what an epic ending
okay i've got to go into complete
darkness wind this up pull it out and
pop it in here gather tape this put it
into this bag send it off to my friends
in london they're gonna scan it then
digitize it upscale it to 4k and
send it back here
okay the eight millimeter scans just
came back it's time to edit these two
separate videos but before i do i just
wanted to tell you how epidemic sound
comes into the picture here firstly if
you didn't know before epidemic sound is
the greatest sound and music library on
the internet with something like 35 000
tracks and 90 000 sound effects and
because the eight millimeter camera
doesn't record sound i have to make it
seem like it does by recreating all the
in-camera diegetics which are the sound
effects that happened in front of the
camera and we can imagine what those
sound effects were and i can do this
pretty easily with all the sounds
available on the epidemic site so yeah
sign up to epidemic sound today i've
linked them in the description below i
promise you that your sound and music
game will just go
up okay now to get stuck into this edit
these two edits
okay both videos are done they are
rendering out
once they're done i'm going to show you
you are the judge which one feels better
they do look very different but they
both got a different style they both got
a unique feeling and it's up to you
which one do you prefer here goes
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
um
[Music]
okay if you couldn't tell the difference
between those two videos you definitely
have an eye problem and i would check
that out they are very different
aesthetically however they feel
different too which one do you prefer
the more organic yet flawed image or the
near perfect clinical image as well as
what's your take on this whole film
versus digital debate let me know in the
comments below i'd love to hear from you
also for more videos like this one
please subscribe and turn your
notifications below on so that you don't
miss one other than that don't forget
you're awesome and i'll see you soon for
a new video
am
[Music]